欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
虽然这个礼拜即将迎来了中秋廉价
但是台股不想放假
今天其实涨到只差不到500点
就要创历史新高了
甚至如果还原7月8月的全息进来的话
等同于已经创下历史新高
不过今天可以看到盘面上好像是两样情
有一些是低价股不到100块的
纷纷冲涨停板
还有一些大牛股之前不太动的
像台达电台积电
今天也都转强表态
到底该怎么样来选择呢
像探针卡系列今天是有人跌停的
所以同一个族群里面
似乎是有两极化的状况
这礼拜事情超级多
川习会要展开了
这是十几年来首度
由习近平飞到美国去见川普
而川普也讲了
他已经打造了一支AI的部队
还要任命所谓的AI
还有这礼拜有台积电的OIP论坛
这一些都对台湾的AI股科技股
到底有哪一些正向影响呢
要来好好聊聊
我们到底要不要报股过中秋呢
好来欢迎今天三位来宾
第一位是股市师公又年老师
好师公当然要他以52年的经验告诉大家
中秋节后其实涨面蛮大的哦
大家真的能放心报股过中秋吗
今天师公很猛哦
等下会告诉你
明天台股就會非常接近歷史新高
但是我們選股要有邏輯
剛講到川席會現在講說會前會談得非常好
到底談了哪些事情
所謂的AI部隊 AI沙皇
到底受惠台灣的廠商有哪一些
節閒想要比較避閒的或是想要報股過節的
其實設備股可能會是一個很棒的選擇
等一下來告訴您囉
好第二位是我們的題材獵人汉煒哥
好汉煒哥來也要講
现在盘面上双连很厉害
不是捷运站的双连是连发客跟连电
带动所谓的连家军
等一下来教您了
里面还有很多地位阶的中小型股
一旦补涨锐不可挡
那再来如果您觉得从1700 800档里面
悬骨很痛苦
其实证交所有一个指数叫普玉指数
里面帮您筛出了300多档
有传产有电子叫普玉
就是还没有完全发光
等一下浩远哥帮您挑
裡面有即將成為一塊非常厲害
淬欲的好股票是什麼喔
好第三位呢
是我們理財達人秀首代IP製作人
也是普惠投顧的分析師于晨
好于晨又來啦
那于晨今天來要聊什麼呢
他也是看聯發科
衝所謂的5000塊錢
將會帶動台股ESIC的大行情
ESIC有人創高
例如聯發科跟創意
有人第一位接
再來第二個受惠的就是封測股
但风色股今天两样勤啊
100块以下的涨停板
但是数千元的像尹薇跌停板
高跟低怎么选
等一下于晨有一套很棒的法则
要来教给大家
好首先有请尤年老师
好这个这礼拜四天
每天都有忙的事情
穿席会啦
然后还有OIP论坛啦
Meta又有开发者大会
大家只想问一件事
今天还原全息几乎是创历史新高的
我們能不能報股過到廉價後要選誰
我們先能把這三天過好嗎
說得對
這三天我們要做什麼
其實我這樣子講
從我上個禮拜我就認為說
這個磐士應該有機會往上走
是
OK 好
那麼只是說它會走到什麼時候
走到什麼時候
其實還要看未來的局勢的變化
政治局勢的變化
那個是比較重要的
那我們先看看這禮拜
這個禮拜我是覺得周縣收紅
大概不會有太大的問題
唯一的問題是
能不能夠在這個禮拜
創歷史新高
這個是我認為唯一的問題
好 因為它這樣磨來磨去
我剛剛只好使出還原全息已經創高是 對 沒錯那我們真正要創高的是我們不要還原全息我們不要讓它讓我們一步
我們要貨真價實創業性高
其實也沒有什麼困難度
你看看 482 18
現在已經47 718了 對不對
所以只差剛好500點而已
就差500點
500點你看今天我們漲多少點
538點 對不對
所以施工你只要
對不對 正壁一揮
明天就500點了
對 OK 好
沒有啦 我們先預告一下
我認為明天最高點應該是48 209
48 209 你講那麼清楚
就差一點點 意思一下
OK 好
那麼我們先看一下
我為什麼認為說
這個禮拜周縣收紅的機會很大
第一個就是川席會
川席會它是怎麼一回事
其實大家去注意看
每一次在川席會之前
这个美国股市都会涨
因为他都把它当成利多
因为不可能更坏了
不可能更坏
所以利多
好 现在会前会
双方都表示谈得很好
谈得非常好
正式的会议是9月24号
9月23号习近平就到了美国了
然后他们会先会谈一下
会前会先谈一下
然后9月24号正式谈
其实这一次的重点
大家都會把它擺在
就要AI 還有關稅戰
還有稀土供應這些經貿領域
可是我覺得這一次
習近平他身負一個非常重要的重任
就是可能他會試圖調停
美伊之間的矛盾
所以剛才趙豪有問到我就是說
中秋節過後還有沒有行情
那我們就看他們會談的結果怎麼樣
因為今天川普還在對伊朗放話
那整個歐洲其實現在也很亂
因為說俄羅斯在對他們
做一些混合式攻擊
所以感覺上戰士很亂
但似乎沒有反映到今天台股的盤面
是 對 其實不只是台股
其實你去看韓國股
今天表現也還不錯
對 就雅股沒在理
對 那美國的美股的電子盤
今天也很強
好 美股也沒在理
對 有人沒有人在理他們
是因為打仗的事情
大家都不理了
那我們現在就要看
我是覺得這一次
真正重要的任務就是說
看能不能夠調停美伊之間的事情
那我當然我是認為說伊朗
它不太可能在美國期中大選之前
會放軟
可是我覺得應該會有某些的承諾
好 然後我們再來看
過去10年中秋節後
平均台股的表現 你看
過後5日上漲的機率80%
後20日60%
三個月更了不起 90%
也就是因為進入第四季
看來漲率就是非常高
是 對 沒有錯
那當然最慘的一次
就是民國77年的時候
中秋節過後
連續崩盤19天
是
那是在中秋節過後
中秋節過後
過後就開始了
連續這個19天的跌停板
不過那個時候
那個當然是有特殊因素
所以這一次除非有特殊因素
不然的話
中秋節過後應該
可能會技術性的回檔
可是我覺得應該
再差也差不到哪裡去
好 所以這個禮拜
連那個三個禮拜
就四個交易而已
多空的公式會比較不連貫
這個是比較麻煩的地方
我認為它是應該會處於
一個區間震盪的走勢
這個禮拜收紅沒有問題
然後接下來的三個禮拜
兩個禮拜
可能會呈現區間震盪走勢
高點我們暫時看49,500
不要看5萬 這樣子就太明顯了
OK 49,500
那也4999嘛
對
低檔大概最多就是46,400這邊
應該會有支撐
這個華爾街大部分都用利多
來解讀川席會
所以全值股相對會比較強勢
所以這個禮拜上半週
就禮拜一 禮拜二看全值股
禮拜三 禮拜四
就看中小型的股票
為什麼呢
因為丙種結算賣壓浮現禮拜一 禮拜二賣壓是最重的時候禮拜三 禮拜四賣壓解除了為什麼賣壓解除呢因為禮拜三買股票的話你下禮拜二再付錢就好了
所以禮拜三禮拜四
買盤會進來或會進場
所以節前我覺得可以做低進高出
少量短線的操作
那節後試情況加碼或減碼
至於說低價股
我覺得低價電子股
可以暫時BB風頭
今天很強
對 宏基 群創 健漢
這種已經有
它有實質的基本面的股票
可以注意一下
今天當然
今天大家去看那個
漲停板的一字排下來
全部都是150塊以上的股票
低價網通 太陽能
對 LED
對 你只要是兩位數的股價
就有機會漲停
OK 好
然後我們就過來看
還是看台積電
台積電當初我們是用這個周線來看
我們就說它已經盤到一個尖端了
它就要表態了 對不對
那這一次漲了三天
看起來是已經有一點表態
那現在唯一的就是說
你還能不能夠再繼續出量
再突破2500塊來挑戰2535
那其實我是覺得有機會了
為什麼
因為大家看外資預估
它2027年的EPS是143塊
所以現在預估本益比才17倍
我經常在講
我以前就經常在講說
外資給予台積電的買點
是20倍的本益比
那它現在已經跌破
買點這個三倍了
我覺得應該安全
至少安全
而且短期移動均線
馬上就要形成多頭排列了
你看全部都密集在一起
包括季線都密集
都糾結在一起
對 所以現在唯一欠缺
就是一根長紅
或兩三根的長紅
它就可以把這些所有的均線
全部一起往上拉
那這樣子上去的話
那就不得了
OK
好 然後我們看一下
發獎狀
9月2號的時候有講到發哥
這個其實你一直告訴我們
你非常看好發哥
對 沒有錯
你負你的期待
今天已經突破5000元大關了
另外我們也常常在救台達店
對
雖然是今天它有轉牆的訊號了嗎
沒有錯 好
我們先看這個聯發哥
聯發哥今天是拿日線圖出來看
我們前兩次來是拿月線圖
而且是畫了那個波浪裡
對 所以我們當時講說
在這邊是第四波的盤準波
對不對
現在其實已經正式進入第五波了
所以大家還是可以值得觀察一下
繼續觀察下去
另外台達電
台達電之前大家都對它
灰心得不得了對不對
好不好 好
可是股價上不上去 不上去
雜音比較多一些
對 就雜音比較多
其實真正的雜音
為什麼會有雜音呢
因為第二季 第三季
它其實它的毛利率都有下降
然後出貨不順
然後因為這個原料又漲價了
對它來講的話
都有造成一些殺傷力
可是現在的情況是
第四季它可能要漲價
漲價了
所以它的毛利率就可以拉上來了
再從技術面來看的話
你會發現在這邊
你如果用周線看的話更清楚
這裡已經做了兩隻腳出來
只要它能夠佔上2000塊的話
它這邊就形成一個WD
是
這個WD要挑戰當時的這個高點
不會有太大的困難
為什麼呢
因為這裡沒有什麼套勞量
所以大家可以注意
這檔股票未來的表現
好 兩檔其實大家可以回去看
一檔施工說邪惡第五波展開了
台大電說打好第二隻腳
隨機反彈
現在都驗證
對 OK 好
然後我們再來看
就是因為川普要組織AI部隊了
那麼川普還
他認命一個新顧問
AI沙皇
是喔
是不得了
哇
對
施工去應徵一下
我們
不用啦
那個
隨便去當個跟班就吃不完
OK 好
那川普在喊說
AI堪比工業革命
確實沒有錯
他真的堪比
這個工業革命的那當然之前有人說有些放話就是說我們要減緩請問一下誰這個時候誰能減緩對不對其實川普也在講這件事
就是他要加快
他沒有要減緩
對
因為現在大家都已經上車了
然後特快車在跑了
你都在緊急上車
會翻車對不對
OK 好
那麼當然這一部分
是屬於台積電的
台積電工程概念股
然後這一點以下
它是屬於PCP的
PCP設備
設備的概念股
當然你可以看
今天PCP的概念股
表現是比較強的
這個台積電的概念股
表現比較弱
可是表現比較弱就是不好嗎
其實不見得
我們來看一下陽機工程
這檔在這個年線的附近
混了一段時間
對 它是除全息之後
因為它這次除全息
全息值很大
所以它直接跳空下來
看起來很弱的樣子
可是他在這裡
已經做出了一個三尊底了
已經做了三尊底
而且守住這個年線
而且它短期的移動均線
也開始糾結在一起了
五日線 十日線
跟月線糾結在一起
大家注意看一下
它今天開平走低
看起來很弱對不對
可是你去看量價的關係
它今天量
它在上禮拜五的量是很大
一個大量出來
然後拉出一個長紅
今天跌下來立刻量縮
所以量價配合度是沒有問題的
技術面來講的話
它現在的本益比
預估的本益比大概才17倍
如果它來填息的話
它除息前的那一天的收盤價是706塊
它如果來到706塊的話
它的這個本益比
也只不過19倍而已
所以我覺得它的本益比
非常低的情況之下
那應該是有機會來挑戰的
當然在這邊
還有這個半年線跟季線的壓力
這個技術性的壓力
它突破
只要出量 突破問題不大
它現在的問題就是說
能不能夠完全填息
現在目標也在這裡
我覺得它是有機會的
因為它今年的技術面
基本面來講當然沒有問題
它第二季EPS也創了歷史新高
累積這首訂單要超過500億元
所以能見度一直到明年年底
所以這支股票我覺得
現在看起來很溫吞
可是我覺得它在過去這一個多月
比較像在裝飾
好 你看到台股都只差500點
就要創新高
還有貼在年限附近的
而且還是設備股
還是接單滿手的
對啊 而且還賺那麼多錢的股票
OK 再過來又是8021的肩點
好 也在混
對 肩點它跟剛才這個陽基不太一樣
陽基在底部混
像它這一支股票
其實你可以看
它是在這個半年線 季線
所有的短期的移動均線
短中期的移動均線
全部通通線糾結在一起了
那它已經站上去三天了
好 我們就要接下來
我們現在就要觀察
重點就是說
它會展開一個噴出的行情
然後把所有均線都往上帶
還是來一個跳空下跌
把所有均線往下帶
是 我們等一下也問一下
陳俞辰好了
對…
因為他馬上就要決定了 OK
那可是我們按照基本面
來看的話
8月營收年生97.7%
再創歷史新高
累計的也是一樣
它累計的營收
上半年的累計營收
已經超越去年全年了
OK 好
那麼所以它是
而且它這個探針的價格
應該會一直漲
漲到2027年
所以我覺得說
在這支股票基本面沒有問題
現在技術面看起來
也沒有什麼很大的問題
現在唯一欠缺的成交量
成交量出來的話
這支股票應該有表現的空間
好 已經站上所有的均線糾結區了
對啊
這照理來說應該要
往比較好的方向表達
是嘛 不然這費勁的心力
把這些所有的移動均線
通通糾結在那麼狹小的方向
它這個區間的範圍只有10塊錢
是
10塊錢而已
這個所有的均線都在這邊
所以應該是噴出才對吧
好 這邊非常謝謝施工 雲南老師
謝謝